[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATIE RICHARDSON:
One of the things
that is a little
different in how
we approach this is
that certifications
does require a lot of
professional experience.
You have to have hands-on
experience with our tools
in order to do well on
the certification exams.
So that's not something that
comes easily with training.
But we definitely collaborate on
the scope of our certifications
and the scope of the training.
But we do emphasize that,
in addition to training,
you need a lot of
hands-on practice as well.
Qwiklabs is one amazing way
to get that hands-on practice.
If you maybe aren't
using certain tools
in your day-to-day, you
can use labs to also get
some of that experience.
For our professional
certifications in particular,
the multiple years of actual
professional experience
is very critical in
order to perform well
on those certifications.
One of the challenges
with certification
is making sure that that
the individuals that you're
certifying actually
have the skills that we
are saying that they have.
And that's something that
is very difficult to do.
But that's why we follow
a very rigorous process
with the design and the
creation of the certifications.
And it's something that we're
constantly looking to improve.
I think in addition
to that, it's
why we do recommend that
professional experience,
so that you're not just
cramming for a test.
It shouldn't be something
that you just go and hope
that you pass, but really
feeling confident in the skills
that you have.
And that's one of the
goals of getting certified,
is really increasing
your confidence
so that you can go into
these new projects,
go into these customer
meetings, and have confidence
that you have the skills
to really perform well
in your job role.